From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We're rolling.
Today is Wednesday, September 14, 2011.
My name is... I'm here in some voices, John Hume.
But we'll finish the intro and then we'll pause.
Okay. Wednesday, September 14, 2011.
My name is Joe Mosnier, the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with the videographer John Bishop.
We are in St. Augustine, Florida at the Bayfront Hilton Hotel to do interviews for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And broadly speaking, our host on this visit has been local civil rights pioneer Dr. Robert B. Hayling.
And Dr. Hayling, thank you for all that you've done to make our visit possible and we're really looking forward to the conversation.
Thank you and we're so indebted to all of you who have made this possible.
Thank you so much.
Well, we're delighted to have a chance to visit.
Let me ask you to start today by just talking a little bit about your family in Tallahassee.
Coming up.
Yes. I was born in Tallahassee, Florida, November 20, 1929.
My father was an instructor on the faculty of Florida A&M, which was college at that time in the Industrial Education Department.
His specialty was tailoring.
And my mother, for many, many years in our developmental years, was a homemaker.
But she was out of New Orleans, Louisiana, of Creole extraction.
My father was from Grenada.
And therefore, he had to acquire his citizenship and all.
And he taught at Florida A&M for Generalize, because some said 32 and some say 34.
So I say 33 years.
There were four children in the family.
I have an older brother, Charles Hayling Jr.
I was 18 months older than I am.
I had a sister who is deceased now, Francis Hayling.
And then my youngest sister, Yvonne Hayling Clark, is now retired living in Sarasota, Florida.
We all acquired our basic education of college through Florida A&M.
And then went on every child in the family acquired an advanced degree beyond a college degree.
And the other three were involved in education and guidance and so forth.
And I was fortunate enough to go into the Air Force as a college graduate on August of 1951.
After three months of basic training in the Air Force, at Lackland Air Force Base, San Antonio, Texas,
I was admitted to the hospital, or we said medical assisting training program,
that the Air Force had a Sheppard Air Force Base, Wichita Falls, Texas.
And after I completed that training, I was admitted to the staff of the local hospital on the Air Force Base.
And the Air Force Base has a medical technician.
And they asked her to allow me time and to acquire the knowledge as a laboratory technician to make application to Officer Candidate School.
And I was fortunate enough to be accepted and graduated from the Air Force Academy's Officer Candidate School.
No, but Academy, we can cross that out.
It's just the Air Force Officer Candidate School across our Academy.
Yes, because we have the Air Force Academy 9 Colorado Springs.
But, and commissioned as a second lieutenant in the class of 52D, which was December of 1952.
And as Lackwood Havett, I was assigned to an extremely good assignment of Rev. Thomas A. Wright Sr Patterson Air Force Base Daytono Hyle,
as a Aeromedical Researcher and the Biomedical Laboratory that I was assigned to.
And my department field was toxicology.
And I will research ran from forensic to biological to all forms of toxicology.
And I enjoy that work immensely and was way out of my class because as a lieutenant, those kinds of assignments were stranger than Hens' teeth.
And that's a plumb to be assigned to Rev. Thomas A. Wright Sr Patterson Air Force Base with all the in-depth and high-type research that was going on.
And many times, all my peers were captain's majors in lieutenant colonels and on up the line.
But after a period of time, I had called out a space for a first lieutenant to participate in all.
And to my chagrin after being accepted to dental school and asking for an early release from the Air Force to attend dental school,
I was counted off it with an early promotion to captain if I would consent to stay and continue to work that I was involved in, said no way.
All my life, I had always wanted to be a dentist or a veterinarian.
And once I was accepted to dental school, there was no turning back.
Even though in the interim period, I had married my college sweetheart and brought her as a school teacher from Miami, Florida to Dayton, Ohio.
And we enjoyed a year of whatever because she was the homemaker as the wife and had the privileges to the office club and to the can't come to the cemetery for shopping and everything else.
And we also had acquired a box of puppy, a dog.
And we named the dog, Mandana.
And we enjoyed training, watching the dog grow and training the dog and all the activities.
And she had real misgivings about giving up that line of livelihood and also status of living because we were still in the various segregated phases of America.
And even though we went Ohio and everything else, we didn't feel extreme pressures or whatever.
But we knew that the wave of change was sweeping over the USA and she consented.
Even though we had to break up the apartment and everything else and all.
And she went back to Miami to live with her parents and everything else.
And spent some time in Tallahassee with my parents.
And while we were getting adjusted because everything was so school started in 55, September.
And at Meharry.
And we had to kind of break down everything else and whatever.
And get her situated and all.
And then get me into Nashville and it ensured order.
But we made the necessary adjustments.
And I found that the adjustment to studying took a period of time and especially with my peer groups.
Recently out of college and many had advanced degrees in everything in the various medical fields.
And so I fortunately had the honor of graduating with a class where one of our top, top scholars in my class eventually rose to be the dean of the dental school at Meharry and all.
And so Fred Fielder
And now he's retired in everything.
But that's in many of the other class members.
And so we had a team of tremendous honors and credits in their chosen field.
And several went on to be part time entrepreneurs and financial consultants and things like that.
And so we asked about Turok.
We're very short.
Quick adjustment to the microphones.
Dr. Henry, I wanted to ask that there's so much that we could spend time on.
I would love to hear about your experience in dental school.
But since our focus broadly today is civil rights.
Let me ask about you were in Nashville during some very interesting years and became involved with some folks who would like yourself.
And I wonder if you could talk a little bit about Nashville and how you became engaged in that kind of work and activism.
Yes.
As a student, I was aware of the civil rights activities of Nashville but not intimately involved.
But my jurisprudence or dental law instructor was Z. Alexander Looby.
And it ended up that he was the lead attorney for the desegregation of the Nashville of the Tennessee area public schools.
And it produced the occasion of having his home dynamite it.
And he was on a street adjacent to the dormitory that I was living in at Meharry.
And the morning that they dynamited the front part of his house blew out windows of the dormitory.
Some windows in the dormitory that I was housed in.
It happened that the wing that I was in of the dormitory was further away from his house.
I can't claim that it blew out the window in my room.
But I was a marshal in the dormitory and so forth.
And therefore we were concerned about the glass clean up and getting the windows covered and everything else because it was the exact date I cannot say.
But being school time school started in September I can finish the exact date I have that with me.
But the leaders of the movement that I ended up making a acquaintance with were John Lewis, Diane Nash, C.T. Vivian,
La Theat, I have to get La Theat's first name.
And James Bevel.
And all of these ended up being leaders in latter years in the civil rights movement and all.
And even James Bevel and Diane Nash married.
They divorced later on but I think they produced a family out of that siblings I should.
I produced children out of that union and all.
And I had to get in excuse.
I don't remember now whether I went to the infirmary for illness or I slipped out of a class or whatever.
But I had to be part of the march because students from this university, Tennessee and I University in Nashville, had a April 19, 1960 silent march on Nashville City Hall for a protest with the dynamite of Z. Alexander Looby.
And that was a great day and everything else.
And I think it brought the powers that be in Nashville to their senses that something had to be done and it went on that action or even I would almost say school desegregation went further rather than to be resisted or set back or anything like that.
Was that the first occasion when you would have taken an active role in civil rights demonstration?
I would have to say and check on the years and times but my visits back to Tallahassee, Revan CK Steel.
And then we had Patricia Stephens Due and Priscilla Stephens.
There were two movements in Tallahassee going on, one dealt with the desegregation of the movie theaters and I think restaurants and CK Steel led the movement to the transportation system, the buses, the bus system in Tallahassee.
And his movement was so powerful that it led to the bankruptcy of the bus system and all.
And now at the bus station in Tallahassee, there's a life-size monument of CK Steel for all the world to see.
And I have also made the acquaintance of Patricia and her husband who was John Due who came here as a young attorney to help us in synodistine.
And they went on to achieve prominence in the civil rights field and they also wrote a book, a cult wrote a book called Freedom in the Family.
And to this day they are still speaking and touring and attending conferences and meetings and speaking of their ventures because the most prominent one that I remember, these two young ladies were housed in a jail setup in Tallahassee with wire-thensing around them.
In a setup where they had access to I think a Camo facility and a Facebook but no privacy.
And they had to guard each other, take off their clothes and shield the other one as best possible to try to retain some sense of dignity when taking care of their personal needs and all.
And I still don't know at this time how a city like Tallahassee, because Tallahassee was the seat at that time of Florida State University for women and the University of Florida in Gainesville was for men.
And I should say for white women and white men and all. And then we had Florida and in college at that time in Tallahassee and was the capital.
So we weren't talking about some backwards out, back type community and all. But there were extreme battles and resistance for Tallahassee for complying and to racial desegregation.
But all of these magnificent people and Reverend C.K. Steele and Reverend Dan Speed made trips from Tallahassee to come to our freedom rallies in St. Augustine.
And many times spoke either as the principal speakers or auxiliary speakers for the various rallies and naturally they sent us financial support.
Tell me if you were about how the experience in Nashville and those years you were in dental school, how it shaped your emerging sense of what role of any you might have in ongoing civil rights activities.
And I had never had this point in time had no idea, never ever thought about leading movement or participating. Naturally I was a 10 rallies and I was a proud NAACP and things like that.
How did you make your choice to come to St. Augustine?
I had Florida had a educational system set up because Florida did not have dental schools. And at that time the white students from Florida went to Emory University University in Atlanta, the dental school.
And the Meharry was given a supplement or bonus of a thousand dollars per year for any black male or female attending dental school from the state of Florida.
And therefore I think along with my service record or academic record of what have helped me gain entrance to the Harry because the school in addition to all of my tuition and all and then I would also have to admit because of my service in the F.A.S. I had the benefit of the GI bill.
And that made my educational finances at my Harry a bit able to carry itself or at least not put me in an extreme hole that many students have today for having to borrow money or make student loans and so forth.
I also had the good fortune of working in New York each summer as a sky cap for the Port Authority of NY/NJ. And I was a sky cap at Newark Airport from 12 o'clock at night until 8 o'clock in the morning.
And from June until Labor Day I worked many times six and seven days a week. And in the daytime I served lunch or dinner at a big two story restaurant in New York and Sheepshead Bay which is on the way to Coney Island.
And this magnificent seafood restaurant and from anywhere from four to four thirty to five o'clock in the evenings until 8 thirty or nine o'clock at night caught the subway up to Grand Central Station and the bus over the New York Airport.
And this was enhanced and that my relatives, my father's sister on Hester and other relatives and all gave us accommodations for living because my wife came up to be with me.
And she enjoyed playing the role of the wife because we had a system that once I got to Grand Central Station I would call them and they would get my back water and everything else ready and all and my breakfast.
When I came in I had breakfast and had a good hot bath to go to bed to get in some sleep time between arriving in Brooklyn and having to be at the restaurant for four to four thirty in the evenings.
But this restaurant and that experience was so magnificent because they used between a hundred to a hundred and fifty waiters at a time.
This was a massive place and they were world famous for seafood.
They owned their own shrimp boats and fishing boats and everything else.
And many blacks especially young black males on the road up because how would university in Washington D.C., furnished law students and medical and dental students.
And then I don't remember yes two or three of my Harry students also joined us as waiters in New York.
But I don't think many of them stuck throughout the entire summer.
I just turned over at this restaurant with so if you had a buddy system and could get in through the hiring mechanism you could work weekends or strategic times and so forth.
Let me bring you back to that was a strategy obviously for surviving financially during the dental school years.
How did you make your choice to come towards San Otas thing?
I had acquired a convertible books wagon red bottom with a white top and we had an additional automobile.
So after taking the dental exam in Florida for the efficiency or what is called the dental board exam July the 4th weekend of 1960.
And there's a time period where the schools have to be evaluated and everything else and all.
And where you would know whether you will permit it to practice dentistry in the state of Florida.
So I started on the east coast of Florida when all the way down through visiting the various cities were in the space that had black dentists and all down to when all the way to Key West.
And when they came back on the west side up through the Sarasota and then into Tampa and all of that area and then went all the way out to Pensacola and came back to Tallahassee.
And so it ended up of the cities that I evaluated.
Soon Augustine had a very prominent dentist who had met a tragic automobile accident encountered early death and all root off Gordon.
And his office facilities were available.
And in Panama City two brothers, the Buford brothers, one was a dentist and the other was a physician and they had built a nice office facility in Panama City.
And after evaluating and all, I being located in Panama City, I would have been 90 miles from Pensacola or 90 miles from Tallahassee.
So I was sitting out there in the panhandle and what had in somehow I am one because even in Soon Augustine and I hate to admit this.
But I used to get in my car and drive at night after I had finished my office hours to Jacksonville to some of the night spots or some of the late night restaurants just to meet civilization because one of my first comments through the various people was they rolled up the sidewalks in Soon Augustine at sundown.
And which is totally true, I found they drew the curtains and the people had their affairs or whatever parties inside that the general public didn't know about.
But it was a wonderful thing to have Mrs. Gordon, the widow of Dr. Gordon, except me and also offer to introduce me to her constituency or his older patients and all.
And so in December of 60, we had a housewarming and everything else.
And it was a bit delayed or put off and all to a certain point because Dr. Gordon was a chained cigar smoker.
And the entire office reaped of the very expensive Cuban cigars that he bought by the carton.
And he was a gregarious kind of charismatic fellow spoke three languages and dabbled in two others.
And his practice was 50 to 60 or 60 to 70 percent white.
And I kind of inherited that kind of goodwill and all.
So my practice started off with a boom because many people came in saying that they hadn't been to the dentist in the two years or 18 month period.
And so when the office was non-functional, so that made it quite well.
I was also accepted as the city jail dentist, the county jail dentist and the state prison-formed dentist of the county of St. Johns and the city of St. Augustine.
Now it ends up that that wasn't totally because of my professional capabilities and all.
But many of the white dentists, because if they brought you patients from this jail, the attending officer had to have a side on, a pistol on his waist.
And many patients and even the nurses in the doctor's office felt uncomfortable with that.
And so I, being a start-up dentist, blocked off periods of time.
I didn't refuse walk-ins, but I scheduled no patients at the time that they would meet in my reception room going or coming or being there.
Because even when I had the patient in the treatment room, the officer, we would leave the doors open and so forth so they could hear what was going on and what was taking place.
But they generally stayed out in the reception room, was stood in the doorway and all with the treatment that was being administered.
Many of the deputies came to me as private patients and whatever.
And I don't mind saying now because of their contact and everything, their general treatment was usually on the house.
And even to the point that the sheriff, L.O. Davis, who was also a change cigar smoker, had been to my office as a patient.
And you mentioned that you typically did not charge white law enforcement.
I think anyway, it was set up in St. Augustine because of the economy of St. Augustine.
I had to devise a self-finance payment system.
So very few of my patients paid, she always said, out of pocket cash.
So if they made a deposit and started some payment on a treatment plan that we had rigged up for them, we would expect monthly payments or whenever they said they could afford to pay.
So I definitely would not say they didn't pay anything, but they knew that there was nobody breathing down their necks or any hardship about finances for the various treatments that they required.
To the point that many of them brought the wives and their children, especially for check-ups and for dental evaluations.
I may have not put my question very clearly. I thought you said that you didn't charge white law enforcement as a group and wondered if there was a reason for that.
We only had one black deputy sheriff.
And we had a black who freed waters who patrolled a black community, Lincolnville, at night.
He was permitted to have a pistol, but he had civilian clothes.
So did there anything coercive about the arrangement with someone like L.O. Davis coming to your business that you would have been worried about?
Not at the time. I didn't become, so we say, radio active until I got involved with silver rights.
Before then, I was a good fellow.
I was just, I wondered if maybe you were trying to suggest that you were in effect had no real choice but to provide service to people like L.O. Davis without charge.
Never, ever, no arrangement, no formal arrangement was ever made or anything.
Definitely, or it was known ahead of time that whatever treatment minister was on the house or whatever.
Well, let me move on to the question of between you're settling in and opening your practice in late 1960 and all of what will begin to happen in 63.
Can you tell me the story of how in that span of a couple of years you moved towards what would become the prominent leadership position in local movement?
Well, nothing was structured. I'd heard later that the NAACP since we moved under the banner of the NAACP had sent me to St. Augustine to lead the movement and so forth and all.
Well, if the NAACP could ever arrange to send a professional person to an area or to help establish a movement or a chapter or something, they would really be way above the status that I knew of.
I had made certain contacts within the community and gotten to know many of the young people either as adolescents, youngsters who I had encountered in my visits and opening relationships with various organizations within the city and all.
They had also started a movement, our general Edwards mentioned yesterday that they had been meeting and it was under the advisory ship of Reverend Thomas Rev. Thomas A. Wright Sr, who was a local minister, Baptist minister and also an instructor at the Black College, Florida Memorial College in St. Augustine.
His wife was an elementary school teacher but once they got started as youngsters as a youth group in the protest movement, the establishment looked into it and found out that Reverend Rev. Thomas A. Wright Sr was the advisor.
His wife was fired from the school system and pressure was put on the college to get him to cease his sponsorship of the Youth Council and all.
When he refused to do that, he had to leave St. Augustine and move his family to Gainesville, Florida. He acquired a good Mount Carmel Baptist Church in Gainesville, Florida.
Mrs. Rev. Thomas A. Wright Sr went over to Gainesville and acquired a job as a school teacher and as luck would have it, his oldest daughter was the first black to integrate the high school of Gainesville, Florida.
He kept on with the movement even though he had to leave St. Augustine. A delegation of youngsters came to my office and ended up asking me that they had lost their advisor, would I consider advising them and helping them with the movement that they had started.
At that time, as far as I know, it was only picketing and demonstrating and carrying picket signs and things and all.
So it's 1963?
Yes.
The management and the owners of the various shops were not moved. In other words, they tolerated. Naturally, many of them had to be instructed as to how to stay on the sidewalk, how to keep moving and only certain numbers would be allowed per establishment and all.
We made a valid attempt to follow all of the rules.
Why did you fill in my prescriptions for all pain medication or anything else that I would prescribe?
The relationship was very good over the telephone and all. I admit now looking back that I don't think I had ever made an in-person visit to those various establishments.
But even then, it would have been a walk-in and a walk-out because I don't think I was to that point of trying as my young people eventually got around to seeing he wanted was a hamburger and a coke.
But that was what we had to devise for the news media in the end because at the lunch counter, when you sat down, if the waistress asked you, what can I serve you or what do you want?
They would usually say, I want to order a hamburger and a coke and that was acceptable. But as I said at the time, we had no great overall structure.
I don't ever remember receiving any instructions on how to carry out a movement from the NAACP, especially a youth movement and all.
Did you talk in these days with the women who were heading up the community chapter of the NAACP?
Yes, yes. A lady by the name of Fannie Fulwood was the president of the local NAACP chapter. And Mrs. Elizabeth Hawthorne, I think it's Mrs. Elizabeth Hawthorne, was the secretary for the NAACP.
And she offered herself as a secretary for our youth council and all. And Mrs. Elizabeth Hawthorne wrote a bicycle and she lived on the west, on the north side of town.
We were considered on the south side and she would ride across the city even though she had a mental, a bad deformity.
And back in those days, that ailment was referred to as hunchback. And she had a beautiful personality and did excellent secretary work.
And we were so fortunate to have her because she was my stabilizer at the time. Mrs. Fullerwood, through the regional director of the NAACP, a lady by the name of Ruby Hurley, who was headquartered in Atlanta, had gotten wind of the movement.
In St. Augustine and Word had filtered back up through the line of communication that the youth had ideas of stepping up the non-responsive picketing and demonstrating methods that they had been using.
And they intervened and said that the NAACP was not ready to take on a major movement in St. Augustine because of the size and the economy of St. Augustine.
Well, to counterbalance this, the city of St. Augustine was getting ready to celebrate the 400th anniversary of the founding of the city.
And the federal government had appropriated $400,000 to the city to help celebrate and commemorate the entire anniversary period and all.
Not one black, even though at the time the black population was somewhere close to 20% of the city had been appointed to any of the committees involved with the complete year of celebrating the 400th anniversary.
And that was a wake-up call to the racial attitudes of St. Augustine because we had black principals of the various schools.
We had a black who was superintendent of the black schools, Mrs. Reddick and all.
And so, and then we had black professors at the college, Florida Memorial College, and the president, Dr. Perrier, was considered an erudite, educated person who would have been very appropriately appointed to any committees and so forth.
Well, we finally came down to the fact that the city was having a big anniversary dinner, a complete day of celebration that included the ambassador from Spain, a visit by the vice president of the United States.
And naturally the two senators and representatives, the governor and his cabinet and all, we had many, many dignitaries in St. Augustine for that particular day to celebrate and attend the dinner, the big formal dinner.
And this would have been late spring 1963.
Yes.
At the Ponce de Leon Hotel, which is a big magnificent edifice that was so suited because they had a grand ballroom dinner room and all.
So we fired all, we, I fired all for that, to the vice president, to ask him not to attend this segregated function and all because of the exclusion of the black citizenry.
And it generated enough heat that Lyndon B. Johnson at the time sent in his representative, a fellow by the name of George Reedy, about at least a week ahead of the appropriated time for the dinner and all.
And he made many visits to my office, met with many of the other people involved and what have you, because the news media had gotten wind of the letter and all.
And they could see that the pressure was being generated because we had offered the idea that we were going to demonstrate a boycott or do something for this.
Because of the exclusion of the black citizens of St. Augustine.
Well, Mr. Reedy and being neo-fights in this tremendous pressure game, convinced us that the vice president was interested and had read the letter and all and had agreed that if we did not pick it up demonstrate or do anything to distribute it.
And we had to do anything to disrupt the flow and the feeling of the city at that time that he would do his best to see that something was done about this.
We had enough sense, I guess, to say, well, will we be attending? They went run ahead of us and said yes.
So, six, I was either six or eight that they agreed could attend. And we thought at the time we were going to be seated in the Grand Ballroom.
But when we arrived, we were seated in an all-cove that looked down on the Grand Ballroom.
And the only whites that we had the dinner with were the Secret Service and FBI agents.
Now, many didn't identify themselves one way or the other.
And I may have to check with others, but I think Mr. Reedy stayed and ate with us.
And we were still such neophytes in this high pressure game that we agreed to the next morning of a meeting.
And we thought we were going to meet with the City Commission and the Mayor.
That had been your request and that was the barbed wire.
Yes.
And that was agreed to, we thought.
We came again dressed in our little Sunday go-to meeting clothes.
And we got to the designated place.
And there was the Mayor's Secretary and her tape recorder.
Not a single commissioner, not the Mayor, and not one representative from Washington.
So no, Mr. Reedy?
No, Mr. Reedy or anyone representing him.
So we had really been outfoxed.
But we still didn't know any better.
Each member presented their name and address and their position and the various amounts of their involvement with the request.
Because all main requests at the time was a biracial committee to hear and at least give the agreed black citizens the permission to air their grievances before a formal city board or whatever.
The Secretary played the tape so that we knew we were on tape and everything.
And thank this for coming and we left.
To this day, as far as I know, we never ever received a response to that request.
The outfoxed just another way that they took the black policeman who functioned in the Lincolnville, the black community at night, as the police force in that area, who wore civilian clothes.
But he was allowed to have a pistol. They call a side arm.
He dressed him in a police uniform and a cap and all and put him right downtown in Augustine around what was known then as the Old Slave Market, which is a main traffic area directing traffic on that day.
The news reporter broke down the door at my office coming in and knocked at him and knocked at him.
I thought you said you didn't have a black policeman on the force and all.
That was the day of the dinner and he had a presence in the city.
So that was an attempt to see that we had made a false request because they had a black policeman and all.
You soon will become quite strategic then in your subsequent decisions about how to proceed and carry the movement forward.
I'd love to have you talk about how you were feeling after that George Reedy episode and how you decided to recalculate and move forward.
I wish I could say we had a battle plan or strategy.
But many times with the various defeats that we encountered, we had to gather our forces and go back to our think tanks and everything because within a certain, I'm going to use the word we had been outfoxed.
We had been made to look a bit chagrin and that the establishment was fully in charge.
They were able to say that you were making false claims or you're not stating the truth in your accusations and so forth.
So we had to counter that and at the same time the pressures from the national office and the regional office of the NAACP had started seeing you are generating more heat than we are prepared to deal with.
So it meant that various lawsuits and at least public exposure to the media that the city had betrayed us and that the Quadricentennial Committee celebrating the anniversary and everything else.
And we had considered filing a lawsuit to try to stop the usage of the federal warrants and all.
So it meant that we were getting a bit too large for our bridges.
So did that news come to you by telephone typically your phone would ring and it would be Ruby Hurley or someone else passing on that kind of.
She made she made visits.
And we had dinner at the various we had a restaurant right across the street from my office at that time and that restaurant was a godsend because Mr. Pennington was the owner and the operator.
And he had an arrangement with me that any of the demonstrators anybody who came in town and was connected with Dr. Robert B. Hayling and the youth movement and all could go and get a meal.
He had world famous they custom made their ice creams using peaches and bananas and fresh fruit and everything else so the ice cream was world famous and all.
And he would come had a routine at the end of the day and wrap them back on my door at the office Dr. Robert B. Hayling yes.
I fed six people and we had dinners and this and that no okay Mr. Mim coming near me a chance and we issued him a check or cash money for whatever he had contributed at that time.
At this point I also want to give thanks to the Elks members because they eventually made a facility on the second floor of what then was known as the Elks rest on all available to us for meetings and for conferences because we had a large portion of the media people gathering then.
And the TV camera people and all gathering because they had to have an area to set up their cameras and what had you know how did the how did the members okay.
How did the young members of the youth council how did they respond after the episodes you've described with the big dinner and Johnson's visit and the out foxing and how did you manage your relationship with them what was the character of that relationship.
What was your role how did you own advisor unfold well it was a dual head movement and that none of the youth were involved in the negotiations and none of the youth were involved in attending the dinners.
At that time I had acquired the support and I guess the collaboration of Mr. Henry Twine Mr. Oscar Turner or Mr. Clyde Jenkins I would have and I think even then initially I think Reverend Rev. Thomas A. Wright Sr was still in town and many of us it ended up that we had six or eight.
Or eight members could be relied upon to be spokesperson and attend meetings and conferences and all because now we had on paper the request for the biracial committee and we had enumerated things like allowing blacks to take the fireman's examination allowing blacks to take the police examination.
So that they could either qualify or began to make arrangements to see if they could gain employment in those various departments.
At that time other than in janitorial and made service no blacks worked at city hall and all and even with the county administration the same was the thing.
So we had done our homework on the actual local situation and therefore we presented them with the facts that as we saw it and very few ever bothered to count those facts or presentations that we made.
But and the young people never demanded that they be intimately involved they were content apparently to allow the senior citizens and we would almost say like property owners and prominent people of the area.
Now in the meantime the establishment had notified all the black school teachers and also notified Dr. Perrier and all that because at that time the school the college had 300 to 400 full time and part time students plus a staff for why would say 50 to 100 part time students.
Part time and full time faculty members if we could have corral that type of human energetic power we wouldn't have needed any outside help but they cut us off at the knees and that all of these people were instructed that they were not to be involved or they would be in the office.
So they would be in real trouble and that threat was so truthful that many people were totally fearful to the point that they contributed I think under the table but there was no outward showing of support and even many of the young people.
We had college students who broke ranks and came with us who were literally threatened by their instructors because they had to make make up work and work and exams that were administered on certain days one or two instructors almost refused and we had to let them know that if they did not give this person make up work and so forth.
The school would be in jeopardy of a lawsuit and what have you know so we had several battles going on and we had junior law students and law aids but we were able to acquire the services of a Tobias Simon out of Miami who was ACLU attorney and a tremendous fireball civil rights activist.
He was taken away from us all too soon. He participated in the Boston Marathons and had a very credible time and everything else and all and within a day or two after completing that race and all he suffered a heart and died.
Can you tell me about how you responded in the summer of 63 as the momentum heated up on the occasion when some students went downtown and were arrested and what would lead to the hearing in front of Judge (Charles) Mathis?
Well in the meantime we also had a prominent senior Augustine fellow who was a student in North Carolina. I'm going to say NC A&T but I would stand corrected if it's not but I know it was an end his name was Hank Thomas Hank Thomas.
Before I go further to say he has since gone on to become an extreme entrepreneur" owns two or three McDonalds in Atlanta and two or three Marriott hotels and so we are very proud of Hank Thomas.
And it happened in Freedom Rider and was a Freedom Rider and all but he even did a one man sit in at one of the drug stores and all and was arrested and his bond was a hundred dollars and at that time that was a big bond and through the great line and all.
The NAACP let it be known that Sammy Davis Jr. had put up the hundred dollar bond to get Hank Thomas out of jail but also part of the instructions from the local establishment was get him out of town.
So after he was released he had to leave in Augustine and all but at least the movement had been started because the word came throughout the community and all that Hank Thomas had been arrested and retained overnight but was released after the NAACP had been arrested.
It's posted the hundred dollar bond and so but the tie in that we did not know at the time of Sammy Davis Jr. and putting up the bond money and all and we had to escalate our movement in that the young people got tired of coming and being instructed in nonviolence and having
conferences and presentations and all because they became conscious of the newspaper publicity and so forth and many of them didn't take newspapers at home so whenever we came across articles and news of interest and all we made sure that all the members attending our various youth movements had access to that bit of information
because many of them had parents and family members working throughout the community so various people had relationships with as we heard yesterday and all Mrs. (Gwendolyn) Duncan mentioned that Mayor Shelley who was a practicing physician was her family physician and all.
And even I admit Mayor Shelley at various medical and dental conferences and meetings and that I had been accepted to the local dental association and had gained active membership and all as the first.
And that through the local membership quite qualified me for state membership so I was able to obtain the rank of the first African American dentist admitted to the local county state chapter of the American dental association with full membership and privileges.
Others I think in black dentists in various locations it been kind of me honorary membership but not practicing but as luck would also have it the dental association rotated their positions in the organization
and when it came time for election of officers I went to that meeting but apparently enough pressure had been put on the dentist that they said the meeting had been canceled and all because I would have been in line since it was a rotating on position in whatever if they had allowed me to vote at that time and get in line.
I could have moved up and they had envisioned over a period of time I could have ascended to full presidency or leadership of the local chapter in organization so that meeting was canceled and I think by then it had become known that they had created kind of a misstep or sand.
And at various times I knew about the other meetings by other dentists calling me saying are you coming to the meeting tonight and I would have to say is there a meeting in whatever the secretary hadn't called my secretary to tell me that we would be meeting.
Excuse me just once I saw that's positive. We're back.
In September of 63 the clan scheduled a major rally and you and some others had a very faithful day I wonder if you could describe that day and what happened.
Yes the local clan chapter apparently I think they call it cladden had been all downtown passing out hand bills announcing this big clan rally and people traveling up and down US one had seen over a period of time over in a field that they were erecting this gigantic cladden.
Across and all and this were and I guess they were putting out chairs or benches of what had been but a clan leader by the name of Connie Lynch out of California was coming to be the main speaker at this rally.
And also I must admit that the other clan leaders like J.B. Stoner out of Atlanta and all they had called in the big guns of the clan movement to come in to do what they had to do to put a damper on this St. Augustine movement.
And so we felt so moved that we would go out that night and thought that we would not be in in fringing on the movement or on the clan rally anything to park along US one on the roadside that we could look over into where the clan rally and everything else was being held.
Before we knew anything after we parked and stopped they knew the car you know and they were for us of James Jackson of Mister house and James house and and clad Jenkins and myself.
When we looked up there were clansmen with guns in the front of the car and in the rear of the car and house was driving the car and he thought he knew a side road or whatever we were thinking to escape.
And he took a side road and lo and behold the clan had dug a moat a ditch across the roadway and we had to come to our stop to keep from going into that ditch and when we knew anything we were surrounded by clansmen ordered out of the car.
And all and the physical punishment started at that time and they took our wallets and you know personal effects and in my wallet they sold my identity and everything else and also discovered an end of the CP card.
And therefore that was the and the stand the impetus for them to really start beating us the beating was so severe with ax handles and baseball bats and all that we were ushered up to and eventually on stage of the where the speaker was.
And we were piled on top of each other semi conscious like cordwood on top of each other on the stage on the stage and by then the violence was so that many of the clan attendees had started leaving the area and everything else and rather than chaining I think chaining
and Episcopal priest of Daytona Beach had infiltrated the group and wore a personal recorder and had been able to record the speakers and everything going on at the clan rally but he saw how this thing was escalating and he back out of the meeting and everything got to his car.
And went to a pay phone and called telehassy the highway patrol in telehassy and reported what was happening at this clan rally and what he saw and everything else and the state got on and I think they possibly called L.O. Davis and the law enforcement and in Augustine and all and they started sending in auxiliary and also support people and everything else.
And so the powers that be knew that outside law enforcement was coming in because the announcer had on the microphone had announced if any of them had ever had the privilege of smelling a nigger burn and I guess the answer came back no or something well for those who have not had that privilege when so and so when he called the name of the person involved returns with the name of the person.
I guess he meant some excellent but he may have mentioned gasoline that he had sent somebody to get they would be treated to the privilege of smelling niggers burn because it was his intent or stated intent that they were going to douse us with gasoline and set us on fire.
But by that time things had degenerated so that people were fleeing and I can't say when the auxiliary policeman arrived or who broke up the meeting or what had it but fate would have it that we were rescued and put in accommodations to be taken immediately to the hospital.
And even at the hospital we were not comfortable going to Flagler Hospital that was the local hospital so we were only treated in the emergency rooms and all and then the local mortician E.G. Chase made his hearse available to us as an ambulance to take us to Brewster Hospital.
And Jacksonville were we were treated by black physicians and felt more comfortable because that was the black hospital in Jacksonville but we knew at that time we would not be I guess have chance to be double crossed or mistreated by clans or clans sympathizers.
So you were very badly injured and you described injuries a little bit?
Well I usually summarize by saying that the injuries I encountered I would take to my grief.
So because I had his injuries I lost 11 teeth and my health right home was because my patients and all were in attendance at the clan rally.
I can distinctly remember somebody say maybe I read it in Mr. Cheney's because he wrote a tremendous resume of his experience but they pointed out that I was a right handed dentist and they made sure that they did tremendous damage to my right arm and all.
If I had not been in certain physical condition to rehabilitate the muscles and the ligaments in this arm I would have had to quit my practice.
So it's the kind of thing that I don't ever like to emphasize that or make like that allowed me to become a rebel or at least was justification for the so-called militancy that I required or something and so forth.
I thought by serving in the Air Force as an honorable recruit and volunteer and giving four years of my life and going all the way through Officer Candidate School at least allowed me to acquire full citizenship.
But I found out that that even that did not allow me to participate and to practice the rights and privileges of the average American white citizen.
So that was a setback in my line of thought and that no one ever could have accused me well it went so far as I have read now you know resume of L.O. Davis saying that the community decided that I was a communist and all of those things and so forth.
Well the leader of the clan was a convicted moon channel Hoss Manucy and is still not known at this time whether Hoss Manucy had ever gone through the rights and privileges of having his citizenship restored because he had done time in federal pen for moon shining.
I could not instill can't equate equal leadership and what he has here's Air Force officer and a citizen of good character and all leading a movement and he is a convicted moon China and all a person of questionable character and all leading a movement and these way he equated its equals.
And the sheriff and all Hoss Manucy were very very close so that the sheriff deputized many of the clan members as auxiliary deputies of his department.
Tell me about how you thought your way through at the end of 63 to step away from the NAACP and turn your attention towards SCLC as possible allies in this effort.
We had run into the in other words we had ruffled the feathers of the complete NAACP national establishment to the point that Roy Wilkins was the president or CEO he was the big haunchel situated in New York City.
And I received several calls at my office from his office and at times he came online or something but they attempted to give instructions to us as to how the movement should move forward.
And I remember distinctly telling him or one of the secateurs of somebody involved that if they had anyone throughout the country that they thought could do a better job of leading this St. Augustine movement send them on down.
But as long as I was on the scene and all and head of the movement I was going to do what I thought was best for the movement and for me.
And so that meant that I had broken ranks and was not willing to take instructions from above.
And so in a day or two later a call came from Mr. Wilkins and I answered the phone and talked with him we were very courteous with each other and has the weather down there and everything else and whatever.
And he mentioned that if we were not prepared to follow instructions and everything from the NAACP the NAACP was prepared to withdraw our charter.
And this was like I'm going to say it to the old Wednesday.
And so without thinking and without even getting permission from the my local support group or even the youth group I said Mr. Wilkins when will you will you be in your office on Saturday.
And he wanted to know what does that have to do with anything.
I say because my feelings are at this time the mailman will bring you your charter.
In other words in the new telling me we're fired I'm saying we resign and I packaged up through Mrs. Elizabeth Hawthorne and all and sent a mail special delivery the charter with a return receipt to New York to let them know that we were going to go on with what we were doing.
And so we were doing what we were doing in Augustine as best we could without their support because we thought what we were doing was required.
This is after Birmingham AL + Selma AL and all you've seen a lot of national surprise landscape by that point and you wanted to go a different direction.
Tell me about how and we were able to mention at the time that we had been double crossed.
Tell me about your decision and how you pursued the relationship that would unfold with Dr. King and SCLC.
It was there that in other words we were out there up the creek without a paddle because on weekends I made trips to Atlanta and naturally trying to carry practice on in the middle of the way.
I think Saturdays and Sundays for sure I was in Atlanta and I made visits with people like Julian Bond, all of the SNCC people, the names, SNCC, student nonviolent court and meeting committee and even met the house mother, (Ella) Baker.
I got to know them and everything else. Then on another weekend and all I got to know people who knew Daddy King" and members of Ebenezer Baptist Church and all.
I couldn't share with the certainty that I met either Dr. King on a passing visit or even Ebeneath on a passing visit.
At that time, CK Steele was in the leadership of the board or whatever SCLC and he had been a tremendous supporter and he helped me make various contacts and everything else for my visit.
Nobody wanted to pick up a trouble making chapter and a renegade group that could cause them trouble.
It was pointed out that Selma and Birmingham AL + Selma AL and all of these areas had been so severe and SNCC was heavily involved in Mississippi and all.
It had almost been fought to a standstill, brought to a standstill and I'm going ahead of myself but when it came time for the passage of the Civil Rights Act of 1964, Lyndon (B.) Johnson, now who had with the Kennedy's murder and assassination had moved from vice president to president.
He had the good graces of the civil rights organization that he wanted two weeks of cessation of demonstrations and Dr. King and the powers that had agreed and other organizations had agreed.
We had been double crossed several times in all and when it came down to the St. Augustine chapter, we said, fool me once, shame on you, fool me twice, shame on me.
We said we were not going to stop demonstrating until the Civil Rights Act of 1964 had been signed.
They had to speed up the signing and everything else and we have checked our records now because I had made statements that Dr. King left St. Augustine and went to Washington for the signing of the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
But I can say with certainty now that on June 30, 1964, he was in St. Augustine and the Civil Rights Act of 1964 was signed Civil Rights Act of 1964.
But he would have had to go to Atlanta or to Daytona to catch a plane to get to Washington so some daylight times intervened so please don't hold me to the quote of leaving exact St. Augustine to get to Washington for Civil Rights Act of 1964.
Dr. King would first come to St. Augustine himself in May of 64.
But prior to that point, you had mentioned that you had developed a very close relationship with the folks in the SNCC office in Atlanta.
You had obviously planned Freedom Summer for 64 and you planned something for the spring break period.
Yes.
Can you describe that for St. Augustine? It was very interesting and led to all kinds of interesting developments.
Rev. William Sloane Coffin Jr, who was involved with the Yale Divinity School, had contacted us and allowed us to end Revan Robinson to develop a relationship.
And they had recruited between the Yale students that, rather than to take a spring break and go to the beaches and all, they would come to St. Augustine and conduct a tutorial program and clean up, fix up, paint up, or whatever needed to be done for about a two weeks period to lend their support to the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
Activity of St. Augustine. That was a coup. That was a publicity dream that we never could have concocted on our own.
Did that come through SNCC or did that come from the folks at the say Rev. William Sloane Coffin Jr knowing through press reports about St. Augustine? How was that connection for?
I don't think we had the support of a national organization.
Because those students and their families and everything raised the monies to get them here and everything else on their own.
But now we also had a setup as I told you through the feeding setup and all that the people who came to us, we gave them at least breakfast, lunch, lunch, and dinner.
Many times we were used as a peanut butter and jelly and cheese and a fruit, apple or an orange and usually a cold drink.
And then they had the rights to go to Mr. Pendman's restaurant and order a meal or whatever they wanted.
So what was the name of that restaurant? I'm going to say the Freeze or I would have...
Yes, and I would get the full name.
I will not double check.
Yes.
So after that spring break season when a number of Northern white college students came to town, the momentum was really accelerating towards May and June.
Well, the reason I said the publicity crew, many of the participants who came, we had white male and females who had never been exposed to black families and see in St. Augustine to their credit.
Many of the black families agreed to house these volunteers in their homes.
So they had a chance to meet these people at the various church functions and all they met people and everything else.
And also in the meantime, somewhere along the line, Dr. King had participated in a rally in Tallahassee and all.
And we made a trip, Mr. Twine, and a group of us made a trip from St. Augustine to be in Tallahassee for that full day.
And so I had a chance, fleetingly, to talk to Dr. King and other support members of SCLC and so forth.
Yeah.
I would love to spend time talking about your perspective on how the specifics of the relationship with Dr. King and SCLCs, you worked out the events of May and June.
See, this weekend trips here escalated and that I made trips into New York to Boston and all of those areas and made visits to Harvard and MIT and other various Esther Burgess who was a husband.
Bishop John Melville Burgess was the first black episcopal bishop in the United States and he covered an area in the Massachusetts area and all.
So we had developed through meetings and forums and all a relationship with various people.
And also I wanted to point out that many of the students who came from Yale went back and they even developed a drama, a stage play and everything to drama to dramatize their experience in St. Augustine.
And somebody played L.O. Davis and somebody played Judge (Charles) Mathis and the entire thing that they presented throughout the New Haven community and all.
And they had influential parents who eventually sent us financial support and all because it is known and has been known St. Augustine could not carry the movement financially and what had been.
So we had to have outside support and with the people from Yale and the people from the Boston area because I think you know that Esther Burgess, Mrs. Rowe, whose husband was in the industrialist, millionaire, Mrs. Campbell, whose husband was an industrialist.
And she was a millionaire from that area and Mary Peabody of the infamous Peabody family and all came to St. Augustine and many other dignitaries who gave us support including Alvarus attorneys and everything else and what had been done.
Everything else and what had agreed to speak and conduct rallies including Jackie Robinson and all but they were not consenting to be arrested and definitely did not consent to go to Yale.
Tell me if you would just for the tape who Mrs. Peabody was.
The mother of the sitting governor, Endicott "Chub" Peabody, Charles Peabody, or the state of Massachusetts and she was the matron of the 72 years of age of the Peabody clan.
I mean it's really a testament I think to your capacity to develop all these powerful relationships because as you say as the record shows you were successful in I mean Peabody spent a couple nights in local jail in St. Augustine as the governor, as the mother of the sitting governor of Massachusetts.
I was arrested with her at the Monson Motor Lodge.
She's a motor love restaurant.
Which is actually I'll just say for the tape it's where this building we're in now stands the hotel having been demolished and replaced by this structure.
I'm just in interest of time we have probably about 10 minutes left and I'm sorry that you may be right.
Please. We have to drive over to Gainesville.
I want to expect two final things. One is just to have you reflect a little bit more on the relationship of all that you did here in its culmination in late June through June and the signing in DC of the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
Just how you think about the relation of the one to the other as you look back.
St. Augustine. I hate to say never ever admitted.
I'm going to say the general citizenry of St. Augustine in that James Brock died.
On the Monson Motor Lodge had the infamous picture of him putting acid in the water with the freedom demonstrators in the water in the pool.
And that picture went all the way around the world. I understand in Russia,
the news paper had him on the front page of the newspaper putting acid in the water when human beings were in the swimming pool.
But he went to his grave and unrequited uncompromised segregationists.
We have since met his daughter. I didn't meet her personally. She has moved from St. Augustine to North Carolina somewhere now.
But she mentioned that she went to high school with black students and all and that she did not retain the same attitude as her father.
But he literally took George Wallace type segregationist yesterday.
Segregationist tomorrow. So segregationist for life.
Tell me about your decision.
I would not be here.
Well, it was a dual type thing in that I had five years to give to the state of Florida to pay for the tuition help that they had given me in dental school.
After five years in a location that they designated because as I told you, they had consented that St. Augustine or Panama City Florida would have satisfied their requirement
and that it was an area of need for a black dentist. So by staying here those five years I paid back the state.
And then also an opportunity had arisen in Cocoa, Florida, Florida which is right next to Cape Kennedy and all.
And I went down and met the local citizens there and developed a friendship of the black mortician, Rudy Stone, who gave me a living facilities and all and helped open the doors through the black churches of Cocoa, Florida to me coming in and opening a practice.
And right away because of the workers at the Cape, my practice took off even though it was a makeshift office.
We were in an elks building and I was next door to a black physician Dr. Jerkins who was an older man but he had a practice going and he helped by referring patients to me and coming as his family and so forth.
And it was wonderful but Lyndon B. Johnson caught us again and that the main heart of that whole establishment at Cape Kennedy was the control center and because of the electronic era the control center could be anywhere.
And he intervened and had the control center with all that big payroll move to Johnson Space Center.
Was there besides the opportunity that Cocoa, Florida presented?
Were there dimensions of your decision that touched on all that you've gone through here and the implications for your family and such?
Or was it exclusively a professional choice to go to Cocoa, Florida?
Professional and also the relationship with Rudy Stone and the people that I met there and then a younger and educated environment because many of my patients starting all worked at the Cape and many were technicians and other scientists involved with NASA and everything else.
In fact several of my patients ended up being connected to the astronaut families because my dentist, my family dentist in Tallahassee Dr. Campbell had offered through my mother to tell Robert to come on to Tallahassee and he can either practice with me or I will give him my practice in Tallahassee.
But as I said at the time I just didn't give complete thought because it would have been more economical for me at the cost in moving.
Because my brother had put in four years in the Air Force and had moved back to Tallahassee now and was housekeeping in Tallahassee and my family had a big house, four bedroom house and everything.
And we grew up in and there would have been accommodations for me and my family.
But I chose Cocoa, Florida and bought a two bedroom house and I thought that by buying the three bedroom house next door.
My plans were to join those two houses but I found out that was in violation of cold in that you can only have one water meter to a house and therefore I was diminishing the second water meter without proper authorization.
So we commuted, the kids went from a house to house, the main house and then back to the other house but we never made a union or a junction there because it was illegal.
Was it easier, final thought? Was it easier to think for your children to come up and Cocoa, Florida than hear after all that happened here?
With my right being a school teacher with a master's degree in biology and all, I have to give her credit for all that my kids attained and did and that they were, I guess, compatible with whatever went on in the family and that they were all good scholars.
And excellent leaders and so forth. And I guess since time is a factor. I had the good fortune and I'm just coming down from cloud nine.
The city of St. Augustine gave me the Award of Valor on Civil Rights Act of 1964 and presented this award to me with the mayor and at least three commissioners and one or two other city officials present at our ACCORD where Dorothy Cotton spoke from her.
From her affiliation with SCLC and Dr. King and we honored the Rev. Goldie Eubanks family with the Dr. Hale and award of valor.
We give a Waterford Crystal eagle-in-flight symbol and it's inscribed as the recipient requests or designates and the you banks family, many of Reverend you banks his siblings came and extended family members and all.
Because I saw those young people grow up as teenagers and all and now we're at the point that many pursued successful careers including school teaching and all and had now reached age of retirement.
And my daughter youngest daughter who was a graduate of Yale crystal and MBA from Stanford came with her husband Chris.
The fair who is Princeton grad and Harvard Business School grad and he is an employee of Apple Inc and the Far East branch and they came from Singapore or their vacation to be present at the event of the presentation and brought my two grandsons.
Roman who is eight years of age at that time and Avery who was six so that complete weekend July the second old 11 has been an experience for me because my oldest daughter and her husband Robin and David came from Mississippi.
My youngest sister and Evonne and her husband came from Sarasota and I had many other extended family members to come from afar to be with me so it was a real celebration.
Let me say it's just a final word I know that even now your work continues you're still active with with with ACCORD with miss Vickers and I think you're meeting with a bunch of folks tonight as you continue efforts here to help continue to improve the city so it's been a great privilege and pleasure to be with you.
I hope we're still recording because I don't think I gave emphasis to the establishment of the freedom for the foot soldiers.
We were let me have you say word about that we were happy of course to have the conversation yesterday with Mrs. Barbara (Edna) Vickers.
You wanted to say a final note about about Mrs. Barbara (Edna) Vickers and Mrs. Barbara (Edna) Vickers who was my neighbor from across the street on it was Scott Street then now is Dr. Hayling Place the street was named for me on June 20, 2003.
I forgive me of 03 June the 20th of 03 and my daughter and her husband came from California at the time they were living in San Mateo and brought my six seven month old son Roman grandson in the baby carriage and the stroller and all to be present for the street naming him.
We had 21 hailings for the street naming ceremony and part of the activity was moved up and that they had mentioned and especially Commissioner Earl Jones that most cities had pay tribute to their leaders in abstenture after they had passed.
He wanted to try to give me this honor while I was still able to smell the roses and so forth and so there was a tremendous tribute and that Earl Jones's mother Mrs. Maddie Jones had been an assistant to me for about three years or more.
Such a brave lady because she came to work every day stayed and supported me when many of my patients many of my friends and others were afraid I was like a leper in that person with leper in that I was to be avoided and that my office would possibly be shot up or dynamited.
And everything if they were there they would have been involved but Mrs. Jones came and stayed as long and as late as we needed to to have the office open and so forth.
Can I ask you to share the sign?
Yes.
I am so proud to present this sign and I bring it with me to all the meetings and we have a ceremony where the various people involved have to come up and touch the sign and try to say which portion of this sign that they helped earn and qualify for.
So it's a little routine and that's the reason I have this with me that we do it and wherever the activists people have gathered we give them an offer.
I did not bring the citation and all because it's in case in a glass in case and therefore we would have been subjecting it to break it and everything so I decided not to bring it in the car.
Could you lift it up just to about that screen? Let me just focus on it.
You can smile.
That's great.
Dr. Hayling, thank you so much.
Well please please please the honor.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.